日本語アドバイス第9回日本語の勉強する
と同時にもう一つの言語を勉強する
っていうことは道元さんとっては難しい
ことだと思いますかはいまあ難しいという
よりも僕にとってもう無理なんですよあの
日本語を勉強しているだけで自分の英語
英語力がもうどんどんどんどん悪くなって
いって
この前だってよ
レントを
テーヌ
の区別つかなかったんですよ専門用語を
勉強するコツ最も効率の良い勉強法学習法
を教えてくださいパソコン用語を知りたい
のであればどうしたらいいでしょうかこれ
はあの
どの分家でも使えると思うんですけど
その分野が
テーマっていうか設定になっている
設定になっているアニメを見つけてそれを
繰り返してみた方がいいと思うパソコンと
かだったらこれ発音わからないから
ちょっとメモ
持ってみたんですけど
シリアルエクスペリメント to rain
がいいんじゃないかなと思うのでもこれ
だったら見すぎないほうがいいね日本で
最も役立つスキルは何だと思いますか漢字
を書く能力
話す能力
僕は a
どっちかといえばスピーキング
話す能力が一番役立つんじゃないかなと
思います最も役立つスキル
お金をたくさん生み出す能力道元さんのオ
ススメのいユーチューバーとかまぁ
コンテンツクリエイターを教えてください
え
自分は特に歴史とか地理学とかコメディが
そしてゲーミング
が好きなのでへまぁそこら辺の人たちを
教えてください youtube を見る
時間があるときは
基本的に勉強になるやつを見てるんですよ
ね
えーなんで
最近よく見ているのは
無かっ
中田敦彦 youtube 大学 t
チャンネルを見てるんですよねその
チャンネルでは
もその中田敦彦さんがええまあいろんな本
の紹介をしているんですねでまぁ例えば
たとえば経済の本とかあその本の解説をし
てるんですよねでまぁ経済もあれば歴史も
あるし原因をあまりないんだけどよく僕が
大好きなのは彼が a 名作と言われる本
とかアニメとか漫画おおおお
交換月にへ
解説解説いうかそれを演技するっていう
ものがあるんですよねそれがめちゃくちゃ
面白くて英語の字幕
がある動画もあったと思うんですけど
ほとんどないと思ってもらった方がいいと
思うんですよねヤクザみたいにしゃべり
たいんですけどどうしたらいいですか
そうだな
椎名林檎の音楽音楽を聞いた方がいいと
思う日本語まなみ学びたいと思っています
がその効率の良い学習法を教えてください
順番を教えてください最初から何を勉強し
たらいいと思いますか a これも
ちょっと真面目に答えてみますね自分の
友達の会マーレスちょぺんっていう形
マットんって言う人がいるんですけど彼が
筆もお勧めしている勉強方法
イマージョン
常に日本語を聞くこと
これが正しい一番効率が良いと思います
同時に全部やろうと思ってしまったら
例えば日本語の発音とかあんまり不幸深く
理解していないのにそれを招いしようと
思ったら
なかなかできないじゃないですか普通
deko 理解していないというよりも
自分が今まで聞いてきた日本語のそう
総合時間でいいのかな
まあその時間は全部足したらまあパターン
20時間とかだったら当然その人が日本語
の発音できるわけがないじゃないですか
だからとりあえず1年間をかけて毎日常に
できるだけたくさんの日本語を聞いてその
後で
ちょっと話してみるそうすることによって
だいぶ
こう
インプットをしっかりしていればなんと
なく
まあ
そうでない人と比べて圧倒的に発音とか
発音とかまぁ文法もそうだけども全部
だいぶ校
骨まで入っているっていうかその状態に
なるから
とりあえずインプットした方がいいで
マッドは ab 4 d 4とえって言う
まあサイト web サイトアプリ
プログラムを作ってるからそれをチェック
してみるといいかもしれない下にリンクを
貼ってみますのであーるますので日本語に
は
代名詞がたくさんありますよね私僕俺とか
いろいろありますよね
えどれをどこで使えばいいかわからない
からちょっとまぁそこらへんについてあと
は移送してくださいそうだなあこれは
必殺技がありますでまあどうすればいいか
というとを
代名詞を使わないことこのようにね自分は
かなり社交的な人であでです
人を離すと話すのが大好きなんですけど
蔚山い外国人っていう風に思われたくない
えどうしたらいいと思いますかそうだな
これは
どんな外国人であっても静かで内向的な
外国人であってもうるさい外国人っていう
ふうにそういう扱いへい表されることある
から
しょうがないと思ってもらった方がいいか
なと思います a 記入 weezer
英語のちゃったーーーー
道元さんのオススメの
漫画とか
リーディングリーディングどどっ海へ
マンガ本とかオススメなやつそうだな
バウンドだったらまあ俺が一番好きな奴は
大好きな漫画は漫画漫画だったかな
ちょっと分かんないんだけど多分漫画だっ
た
モンスターというアニメ
いやまん漫画もあれば読んでないから
申し訳ないんだけど3モンスターって4人
目がめっちゃくちゃ面白くて
a
あーん
初級
の形でも上級でもいいという質問になっ
てるから上級だったらモンスターがいいと
思う
中級でもいいんじゃないかなと思うんだよ
ねなんでかっていう
というとなぜかというとそのモンスターの
設定は比較的現実的なんだよねほとんどの
アニメほとんどじゃないかもしれないんだ
けどだいたいその人気アニメは現実設定が
現実的ではないんだよね例えば
なるととか
事実回戦とか
進撃の巨人とか全部校
異世界で犬この異世界でよくまだその言葉
の意味が多くよくわかんないんだけど
こう現実的ではないんだよね
なかなかな加工
そこに出てくる単語王2通の日常会話
一条会をで使えないんだねこう立体機動
装置とか絶対普通の会話の中で使えないん
だよねでもこのモンスターでアニメは
せっ体がとにかくリアルで設定が現実的て
いうよりも
まあその
そのマンガを読んでいるあなたが不不不不
不不不不不不不不殺人自社殺人者でいいの
かな人殺しの命を得
スクって言うことは絶対ないと思うんだ
けどそのアニメの中で
日常的な会話が多い c
その
日常的という
d の可能も日常的
リアル
現実的なアニメになってるから
おすすめですでモンスターだったら面白
すぎて自分のレベルと合わなくても多分来
ては読みたいはこれは絶対に
ま最後まで観たいという気分になると思う
から
おすすめですに品を上手になりたいんだ
けど日本をジョーズって言われたくない
どうしたらいいと思いますか日本長いんで
すかっていうレベルにレベルにパッセして
から日本に引っ越すことをしたらその日常
的な会話の中で
にその日本語上手回数が劇的に減りますだ
からできるだけ上達してから日本引っ越す
ことだ
me